I share the concern that the humanities
Fields have been completely destroyed by
the libs and by wokeness and the science
Fields have largely been destroyed by by
them but not entirely and maybe you
shouldn't go to college at all I'm
totally open to those things but if
you're going to study something I I
think you should study the liberal arts
not the technical Arts that prepare you
for a job if you want to go to a
vocational school and you want to go to
trade school and you're you're doing
that with your eyes wide open go for it
if you want to get a liberal arts
education then actually study the
liberal arts the point of which is to
help you make sense of your freedom help
you make sense of your culture help you
make sense of these higher things that
you can then go get some on-the-job
training to apply that to a real life
profession so much of our modern
political chaos owes to the fact that
people don't understand anything beyond
certain applied sciences but we don't
understand the bigger questions